ich habe mich unheimlich über eure
vielen themenvorschläge bei whatsapp
gefreut und auch dieses hochspannende
thema hier kommt von euch ihr wollt mehr
erfahren über technische fortschritte
die unser leben immer sicherer machen
und menschenleben retten angefangen bei
argumente duelle tief für die feuerwehr
bis zu computern die krankheiten
besiegen wie das alles funktioniert und
wie viele menschenleben gerettet werden
können jetzt in klingsmoos science und
fiction herzlich willkommen
platz für eventuelle die für die
feuerwehr feuerwehrleute retten
tagtäglich menschenleben und auch besitz
und allen ist klar dass das ein echt
harter und wichtiger job ist mit vielen
herausforderungen und risiken feuer
toxischer rauch der kaum zu durchdringen
ist und eine mehr als 20 kilogramm
schwerer schutzausrüstung
jetzt hat ein forschungsteam auslösern
ein intelligentes system entwickelt das
mit einer wärmebildkamera kombiniertes
feuerwehrleute sollen so ihre umgebung
in echtzeit erfassen können selbst bei
rauch und in der dunkelheit das system
dient der orientierung in unbekannten
räume in denen sie opfer möglichst
schnell finden und bergen müssen
es ersetzt die eher unhandlich und
unpraktische wärmebildkamera und macht
die hände frei konkret besteht das
system aus einem transparenten
bildschirm in der sauerstoffmaske und
einer mini infrarotkamera auf dem hemd
die feuerwehrleute sehen so zwei bilder
und zwar im helm vor sich das bild dass
ihre eigenen augen ihnen zeigen und
ziehen zudem das von der wärmebildkamera
in echtzeit aufgenommene medien bürger
einer der beteiligten ingenieure sagt
dazu wir haben nach einer optimalen
lösung gesucht um heiße und kalte zonen
darzustellen wir haben natürlich rot und
blau verwendet doch wir mussten vor
allem die richtigen farbtöne finden die
auf einer transparenten oberfläche
sichtbar sind
der prototyp wird bereits in der praxis
getestet und das feedback ist gut im
ersten moment ist es schwierig zu
unterscheiden was man gerade sieht ob es
real ist oder nicht aber man gewöhnt
sich erstaunlich schnell daran und kann
leicht mit den beiden sich überlappenden
ansichten umgehen platz drei
notrufsystem autos rufen selbst die 112
an
vielleicht haben es einigen von euch mit
bekommen seit ende märz 2018 müssen alle
neuwagen in der europäischen union der
eu über ein automatisches notrufsystem
verfügen sein name ecall und das wird
hoffentlich sehr viele menschenleben
retten und den straßenverkehr vielleicht
tatsächlich ein bisschen sicherer machen
denn statistiken zufolge sterben täglich
auf den straßen der eu so viele menschen
wie der hamburger stadtteil eppendorf
als einwohner hat nämlich rund 25.500
das ecall notruf system verwendet gps
und eine mobilfunkverbindung um schnell
hilfe zu holen konkret funktioniert das
mit einer eingebauten sim karte durch
die eine direkte verbindung zur rettungs
nummer 112 aufgebaut wird denn die ist
in ganz europa einheitlich das geht
händisch falls der fahrer dazu nach
einem unfall noch fähig ist aber eben
auch automatisch zudem sendet das auto
wichtige daten an den rettungsdienst den
ort des unfalls dem zeitpunkt die nummer
mit der das auto identifiziert werden
kann und auch die fahrtrichtung des
unfallwagens auch die zahl der menschen
die im auto sitzen oder saßen wird über
die anzahl der gurte ermittelt und
weitergegeben auch zeugen und unseren
beteiligte können über die
freisprechanlage infos an den
rettungsdienst übermitteln das ecall
system musst nur um hilfe wenn die
airbags ausgelöst werden so soll
verhindert werden dass bei kleinen
harmlosen ein park unfällen zum beispiel
rettungsstellen umsonst alarmiert und
damit unnötig überlastet werden bis zu
40 prozent weniger zeit so in
städtischen regionen vergehen bis
rettungsdienste am unfallort eintreffen
1500 menschen leben könnten pro jahr
gerettet werden ja wer demnächst nicht
vorhat einen neuwagen zu kaufen aber
dennoch nicht auf solche notrufs
assistenten verzichten wird kann auch
sein älteres auto nachrüsten lassen
platz zwei
algorithmen spüren verbrecher auf wie
beim 1 0 t report sind algorithmen
mittlerweile in der lage verbrechen
vorherzusagen zudem sind sie in der lage
die täter nach ihrer tat aufzuspüren in
deutschland wird solch eine
polizeiarbeit die auf computer
vorhersagen wie predictive policing
genannt in bayern und baden württemberg
beispielsweise laufen dazu pilotprojekte
eine in deutschland entwickelte software
sagt voraus wo einbrecher demnächst
zuschlagen werden das ganze basiert auf
der annahme dass täter nach mustern
arbeiten dass sie beispielsweise orte
bevorzugen an denen es gute
fluchtmöglichkeiten gibt oder aber dass
sie in erfolgreiche gebiete zurückkehren
und wieder zuschlagen genau das sagt die
software voraus und wenn sie sich
zumindest 70 prozent sicher ist schlägt
sie erlauben dann werden polizisten an
diesen ort geschickt in den usa hat sich
der amerikanische journalist thomas hahn
wurf eigenständig eine
ähnliche software gebastelt über diese
sind ist wirklich sensationelle arbeit
hat man ja schon berichtet er hat
zunächst tatsächlich das größte mordfall
archiv der usa angelegt mehr als 750.000
mordfälle hat der hierarchie wird und
übertrifft damit sogar das fbi dessen
archive tatsächlich 27.000 mordfälle
weniger zählen dagegen stehen etwa
220.000 ungelöste mordfälle seine
konkrete idee die entwicklung einer
software die gemeinsamkeiten der
verbrechen identifiziert wie wurde das
opfer getötet wurde das verbrechen
begangen und um welche opfer handelte
sich alle infos zu den morden der
letzten drei jahrzehnte wurden ins
archiv aufgenommen und das
computerprogramm machte sich an die
arbeit um nach möglichen gemeinsamkeiten
der unterschiedlichen mordfälle zu
suchen und es klappt tatsächlich der
software beispielsweise aufgefallen dass
es in indianer 15 ungeklärte todesfälle
gab und zwar mit frappierenden
gemeinsamkeiten die opfer allesamt
frauen wurden allesamt erwirkt und
allesamt in verlassenen häusern
aufgefunden
doch die polizei dort ignorierte die
hinweise von thomas adolph einen
serienmörder im eigenen bezirk undenkbar
doch der ehemalige journalist war
hartnäckig zudem passierten weitere
sieben morde auch diese opfer wurden
erwürgt erst dann handelte die polizei
mittlerweile sitzt der killer hinter
gittern und hat weitere sechs morde
gestanden
das fatale auch diese morde waren bis
dahin von der polizei nicht als morde
erkannt worden tatsächlich ein großes
problem in den usa
achtung 5000 menschen töten dort pro
jahr ohne dass sie dafür bestraft werden
platz eins mit computern krankheiten
besiegen wir haben ja schon mal da war
berichtet und das ist auch echt ein
ziemlich irres ding tech firmen wie
amazon apple microsoft und google
arbeiten tatsächlich daran hautkrebs
durch algorithmen zu diagnostizieren
oder depressionen mit hilfe von software
zu behandeln und herzinfarkte durch
nanopartikel vorherzusagen die
überlegung dahinter
das verständnis von krankheiten sei ein
daten problem das mit hilfe von
künstlicher intelligenz ki computern und
algorithmen gelöst werden kann
das würde nicht nur den gesamten bereich
der medizin sondern tatsächlich die
komplette welt revolutionieren
und hier noch ein paar konkrete
beispiele aus der praxis bei amazon geht
es hauptsächlich um virtuelle
arztbesuche und darum wie sich riesige
datenmengen im medizinischen bereich in
einer cloud speichern lassen google
möchte mit hilfe von software
depressionen heilen und herzinfarkte mit
hilfe künstlicher nano-partikel
voraussagten
wow das klingt wirklich irre und
mittlerweile ist es gar nicht mehr nötig
software zu entwickeln stattdessen
entwickelt sie sich selbst so dass sie
aus daten lernt so bei microsoft projekt
namens hannover computer sollen sich
hierbei zunächst einmal das komplette
medizinische wissen aneignen heißt also
studien lesen und verstehen millionen
von artikeln sind ja verfügbar und
täglich kommen neue erkenntnisse hinzu
wie sollte ein mensch mit kommen hier
unmöglich kein großes problem dagegen
für maschinen
sie sollen ärzteteams in zukunft dabei
unterstützen personalisierte
behandlungsmethoden zu finden computer
könnten für jeden einzelnen patienten
für jede einzelne patientin individuell
angepasste medikamentencocktails finden
statt einen wirtschaft nach dem anderen
zu testen könnte intelligente software
auf grundlage der genomischen daten der
patienten die literatur nach der
perfekten medikamentenkombination
durchsuchen auf einen schlag können so
tausende von kombinationen analysiert
werden und dem ärzte-team vorgeschlagen
werden durch die zusammenarbeit mit dem
menschen könnten die maschinen dann
sogar immer weiter dazulernen und ihre
intelligenz ausbauen eine große vision
der tech firmen ist es übrigens auch die
menschlichen biologie irgendwann einmal
steuern so können wir eine software dna
könnte dann beispielsweise programmiert
werden ebenso wie zählen dieses einem
forschungsteam der stanford university
tatsächlich schon gelungen und soll nun
weiter perfektioniert werden dazu muss
man verstehen wie sie funktionieren dann
so die idee ließe sich eine
programmiersprache erfinden um ihre
steuerung zu übernehmen krebs in einer
zelle ließe sich so also erkennen und
der computer könnte in diesem fall das
kommando selbstmord befehl natürlich nur
für die krebszellen ibm hat eine ki
entwickelt die die
die dna sequenzierung eines gehirntumors
schneller und zuverlässiger analysiert
hat als das gesamte team der
menschlichen expertinnen und experten in
israel arbeitet ein forschungsteam an
einem virtuellen gesundheits assistenten
der die patientinnen und patienten im
chat berät die maschine hat zugriff auf
eine riesige datenbank und allen
aufnahme protokoll bei wunsch zudem auf
die persönlichen daten der patientinnen
und patienten na klar gibt es hier auch
kritik die datenschutzprobleme werden
angeprangert und ja wir müssen
tatsächlich vor und nachteile sehr
sorgfältig gegeneinander abgewogen
werden wenn er als erstes neues zu
bahnbrechenden erkenntnissen erfahren
wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von
mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert und zur begrüßung gibt es ein
kleines kuli einfach hier draufklicken
und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
genommen mit der glocke vergessen hier
geht es weiter dafür auch draufklicken
mit krebs mit smartphone diagnostizieren
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran